economía en directo américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniel hablando
andan y muy buen día bienvenida feliz
jueves además ya nos deja porque se va
de vacaciones qué rico nosotros seguimos
aquí trabajando pero vamos a hablar del
bitcoin porque hace un mes entró como
divisa oficial en el salvador hola raúl
pues sí lo voy a extrañar aproveché me
hoy que estoy de vacaciones mañanas no
olvide este país como lo sabemos fue el
primero del mundo en introducir esta
cripto divisa como moneda de curso legal
después de 20 años que llevaba con el
dólar como única moneda el presidente en
allí buque le fue blanco de críticas y
hoy en día la moneda digital sigue
generando rechazo para gran parte de la
población pero veamos cómo ha sido la
evolución del precio del beat coin raúl
según la agencia bloomberg un día antes
de que el salvador implementará la
medida el bitcoin superaba los 50 mil
dólares y en una sola jornada cayó más
del 17 por ciento después ha tenido
varios altibajos y en los últimos días
la cripto moneda más popular del mundo
ha vuelto a pasar la barrera de los 50
mil y hoy se ubican 54 mil 600 dólares
casi 55.000 daniela pero le pregunto
este aumento de precio que implica para
el país
el gobierno del salvador
no sólo introdujo esta cripto divisa
sino que también compró setecientas de
ellas en esa semana que él introdujo ese
7 de septiembre esa inversión valía unos
30 millones de dólares y hoy vale un
poco más de 38,3 millones de dólares
esto significa que subió un 27,2 por
ciento pero así como sube pues también
puede bajar y esto es lo que
precisamente critican de este cripto
cteep como dice la canción todo lo que
sube tiene indicadores daniela en
bolivia se puede retirar parte del
ahorro pensional inició el miércoles la
devolución de estos ahorros para las
personas en bolivia como parte de las
medidas para mitigar los efectos de la
crisis del cobi 19 y también como se ha
hecho en otros países como perú y
también en chile
el cronograma particularmente hablando
de bolivia irá hasta diciembre
dependiendo de la edad según la ley
sancionada por el presidente luis arse
en septiembre a regañadientes la norma
comprende la devolución del 15 por
ciento para quienes tengan hasta 14
367 dólares ahorrados y de 2 mil 176
dólares para quienes tengan más de ese
valor una tercera modalidad raúl prevee
que quienes tengan más de 50 años y
menos de mil 436 dólares ahorrados
pueden acceder a todo su dinero pero
decenas de personas se acercaron a las
oficinas de las administradoras de
fondos de pensiones con papeles en mano
y la confusión fue la protagonista lo
invito a que escuchemos a ver yo vine me
dijeron si a usted le corresponde por la
edad y por sus aportes se le corresponde
la devolución total y ahora me salen con
quien no que no es la devolución total
es el 15% y todavía yo tengo que después
devolver ese dinero no hacen el 100% de
la revolución hacen un descuento en este
aspecto porque recientemente nosotros
hemos sacado un extracto más en el banco
nos dicen otro otro otra cifra nos dan y
continuamos con más información de
economía daniela indonesia aprobó una
reforma tributaria bueno lo hizo el
parlamento de ese país asiático
a lo que toda la reforma tributaria
busca aumentar impuestos el iva o
impuesto al valor agregado en este país
asiático subirá al 10% en abril próximo
y al 12% en 2025 también echó para atrás
un recorte planeado de los impuestos
corporativos en cambio raúl introdujo un
impuesto de renta más alto para los
ricos y uno al carbono todo para
recuperar parte de lo perdido después de
que las arcas de la nación se vieran
fuertemente afectadas durante la
pandemia más de un país de américa
latina debe estar envidioso de estas
reformas y stahel a indicadores pues
mire raúl al mercado asiático le está
ilusionando bastante que eventualmente
se reúnan el presidente de eeuu joe
biden y el de china xi jinping a finales
de este año así sea de manera virtual
hong kong el reporto más del 3% en la
jornada mientras tanto las acciones las
acciones europeas a media marcha también
están al alza debido a un pequeño
respiro en los precios de la energía
aunque siguen altos raúl de hecho el
productor ruso de gas gazprom se atrevió
a pronosticar que los altos precios del
gas en euro podría desestabilizar la
economía de la región y es que han
subido más de 800 por ciento este año
daniela hoy estoy que me canto porque el
costo de la vida sube otra vez es en la
cifra el día sí señor treinta y jones el
que me como porque 32.8 por ciento fue
que estuvieron los alimentos no
solamente el precio de vida esto lo
hicieran en septiembre de acuerdo con la
fao que es la organización de naciones
unidas para la alimentación y la
agricultura septiembre de este año
frente al año anterior los precios de
los productos agrícolas pues se han
visto afectados por retrocesos en las
cosechas y una gran demanda china
durante la pandemia y nos vamos ahora a
ver en nuestro reportaje del día daniela
nos vemos más adelante con más economía
en directo americana lo que sí